depuis le début de l'année on a vraiment
l'impression d'être déjà en campagne
électorale est conscient qu'on est en
campagne électorale
lol nous allons former un gouvernement
paritaire on ira au même rythme que les
libéraux on est efficace les chefs de
partis hausse le ton lors qu'ils
arrêtent de fanfaronner on a donné notre
avoir le pouls précieux là les choses
pour qu'elles deviennent sérieuses à
faire des douches et beaucoup dessus
j'ai fait ma question aux grands
donneurs de leçons là certains ont même
déjà commencé à faire des promesses
électorales
mais on va maintenant donner aux
familles du temps c'est nécessaire
d'avoir un troisième ligne nous allons
geler la rémunération des médecins
visites dans les usines painful la
présence des chefs de parti sur le
terrain s'accentue on se retrouve
charlotte on ne peut aujourd'hui se
montre un peu pour avoir nos voix
traînante âge
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a donc donné une chance
aux partis d'opposition de s'organiser
davantage d'offrir une compétition saine
mais on a peut-être en conséquence aussi
modifier les stratégies gouvernementales
notamment dans les choix de politiques
publiques
on encourage à la dépense à preuve la
croissance des budgets des gros
ministère a bondi au cours de la
dernière année
voyez par vous même ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il ya aussi que le budget heures et
que à peu près partout on peut l'étudier
la dernière année qui précède une
élection on assiste à une augmentation
significative des dépenses en ontario on
a choisi de limiter les dépenses des
partis politiques et des groupes
d'intérêts dans les six mois précédant
le déclenchement de la campagne
électorale
ce qui n'est pas le cas au québec
maximum six cent mille dollars pour les
tiers 1 million pour les partis
politiques
l'addition que j'ai prise c'était plus
de 12 les observer le comportement de
nos acteurs en période électorale ce
soit les partis politiques et candidats
et les céréales également le directeur
général des élections promet d'être
vigilants et de faire des
recommandations aux besoins pour la
prochaine fois pour proposer des
modifications et encadré il faut avec
des faits
[Musique]
tous les partis connaissent la date fixe
la date des élections déjà et les autres
partis ont déjà commencé leur campagne
ce que la loi québécoise prévoit par
contre c'est une limite à la durée de la
campagne électorale
celle ci sera la plus coûteuse
il ne pourra donc pas y avoir de
campagne de 78 jours comme ça a été le
cas au fédéral en 2015 fait c'est la loi
qui vient vraiment à cadrer le début de
la période électorale est contenue que
notre loi électorale prévoit un
calendrier déterminant de jours
mais à ce moment l'eau avec la date de m
me fout on aligne l'eau au vote du 1er
octobre la main des élections se
retrouver nous avec un déficit de plus
de 4 il ya tout d'abord le trouble qui
nous a été laissée 1.6 médias on joue le
même film que 2003 je m'en souviendrai
un budget dans lequel damien tout ou
alarme élections en théorie
personne ne pourra plus invoquer cette
excuse c'est nouveau pour le
vérificateur général le 20 août prochain
le ministère des finances va déposer ses
prévisions budgétaires pour les trois
prochaines années et le vérificateur
général va devoir porter un jugement sur
la vraisemblance de ses prévisions le
vérificateur général va émettre une
opinion sur la possibilité pour les
trois prochaines années dont ce seront
les affiches sur lesquelles chacun à
poils qui pourra présenter ses promesses
électorales ou c'est un choix électoraux
ceux qui font la promotion des élections
adapté avance souvent que ça va
favoriser la participation du directeur
général des élections bien entendu je
fais valoir que des élections à dates
fixes permettra également une meilleure
participation
une affirmation sujette à caution au
canada 11 des 13 provinces et
territoires tiennent des élections à
date fixe
dans deux cas sur 11 la participation a
augmenté lors de l'élection suivant
l'adoption de la loi et dans le nouveau
4 la participation a plutôt baissé
l'argument qui est fait c'est que cette
longue campagne permettrait de mobiliser
les électeurs dans les rangs si on veut
plus réceptifs aux messages des partis
politiques
mais cet avantage là pour être compensée
par une fatigue les défenseurs des
élections à date fixe disent aussi
qu'elle contribue à diminuer le cynisme
de la population qu'elles permettent à
davantage de femmes et de membres des
minorités de se porter candidat mais ces
phénomènes n'ont pas encore été
documentés en contexte québécois les
élections de l'automne vont donc
permettre de tester ces affirmations